hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the fun and
exciting topic of the absolute worst
Harry Potter theories to have surfaced
or been discussed in 2022 some of these
theories you may recognize from videos
of mine that have released in the last
year however many are topics I either
didn't have time to address in specific
videos or hadn't come across until now
of course if you have yet to watch my
past videos and some of the topics I
mentioned today I obviously encourage
you to go check them out after this if
you'd like to learn more about them so
without further Ado let's dig into eight
of 2022's most terrible theories as we
make our way through each Theory I'll
explain how some of these can be
completely disproven While others are
well just absurd Hermione is Harry's
sister let's begin with the theory which
I personally feel has very little merits
that is the theory that Hermione is
actually Harry's sister as I mentioned
in my video five Hermione Granger fan
theories ranked worst to best this
theory is almost entirely based on fans
feelings absurd right that's not a
theory my friends that's just well a
feeling this theory is also almost
completely debunked by the fact that JK
Rowling has commented in the past on how
she thought Harry and Hermione should
have ended up together I don't quite
think Rowling would have made that
comment should she have secretly made
the two of them related Hermione's
parents were abusive another totally
weird theory that revolves around Miss
Hermione Granger is one to do with her
relationship with her parents now you
may recall that I've discussed the idea
that Hermione was possibly homeless for
a certain point in time during the
latter half of the series but this
Theory further expands on that idea
claiming that Hermione purposefully
erased her parents memories in an effort
to free herself from their abuse that's
right this Theory suggests that Mr and
Mrs Granger were physically abusive
towards Hermione as the theory goes this
would apparently account for the large
amounts of time that she spent with
either Harry or Ron and the rest of the
Weasley family throughout the holidays
and breaks from Hogwarts points against
this oddly dark Theory include the fact
that Hermione went above and beyond to
protect her parents in the seventh book
she never showed any signs of abuse and
that when we meet her parents in Diagon
Alley in the second installment of the
series there's nothing notably wrong
with them obviously the two Lasser of
those three points are little on the
weaker side since abusive parents can
hide their nature from the outside world
however I think the first point is
strong enough to disprove this Theory
especially in combination with the other
two Hogwarts and Magic it was all a
dream another theory that I have little
love for is the one that I'll admit has
been around for a while but it's just so
bad that I had to mention it it's the
theory that the entire entire series was
all a dream that took place in Harry's
head this idea comes with serious flaws
to start with the Epic Saga that is the
Harry Potter series lasts seven whole
years of course I suppose it could be
argued that a dream can span great
lengths of time so why not years however
it's pretty difficult to argue with the
fact that the Wizarding World has
expanded to other characters including
different protagonists like famous magic
zoologist newt's Commander so how would
a dream transfer from one person to
another with complete histories of the
same universe intact simply put it would
not the dursley's in Harry another
theory that has cropped up a few times
here and there is the idea that the
dursleys were only terrible to Harry
because he was a horcrux that is in the
same way that Salazar slytherin's locket
made whomever was wearing it while it
housed a piece of Voldemort Soul feel
absolutely horrid being around Harry
made the dursleys behave badly this
theory has so many flaws first of all if
this was true why was no one else in
Harry's life impacted by the fact that
he was a horcrux for example wouldn't
all of his friends Ron Hermione Hagrid
have all also been totally rude to him
if this was a real effect of Harry being
a horcrux second of all the dozies were
incredibly rude and terrible people to
others not just Harry so pretty much
this theory is a bust the dursleys were
just bad people Draco Malfoy son of
Snape and a werewolf there's also been a
couple odd theories that have come to
light about Draco Malfoy one that I've
come across recently was that some fans
believe that Draco may have been Snape's
illegitimate son I've literally seen
zero proof to support this not to
mention the fact that Draco is the
spitting image of his father Lucius
Malfoy I've also stumbled upon the
theory that Draco became a werewolf
later in the series while there is some
speculated evidence for this Theory I'm
pretty quick to discount it some fans
have said that he may have been bitten
by greybank who seemed to be living at
Malfoy Manor near the end of the series
so I guess the bite could have accounted
for the mark on draco's arm rather than
it being the dark mark of Voldemort's
Death Eaters as Malfoy himself claims
however that all seems rather
circumstantial and there's just not
enough there to support it in my opinion
Snape was Harry's real father now I just
mentioned the idea that some fans have
speculated that Snape was Draco Malfoy's
true biological father for some reason
theorizing that the perennial Bachelor
Severus Snape was secretly having
illegitimate children all over the UK is
a rather popular one which brings us to
claims that Snape was actually Harry's
real father now as you may recall in the
past I've done a video on what if Snape
had been Harry's father but in all
honesty that was more a theory on how
the relationship would have impacted the
two characters for I truly don't believe
Lily would have been interested in an
affair with Severus
his choice to become a Death Eater was
just too traumatizing and unforgivable
to her but if we forget all that for
just a moment the most convincing piece
of evidence that disproves this theory
is Harry's physical resemblance to his
father James sure there have been some
fans out there who suggest that Lily
could have done some magical plastic
surgery on Harry after he was born but
that just seems totally Bonkers to me
Snape was to be Godfather of Lily's
unborn child along the same lines is yet
another theory about Snape and his
connection with Lily and her child or in
this case unborn child the theory
revolves around the idea that Lily was
pregnant at the time of her death and if
you've guessed that Snape was the father
of this child you would actually be
incorrect in your assumption for this
very vanilla fan Theory claims that
Snape was to be the Godfather of James
and Lily's unborn child a rather boring
thing to theorize about if you ask me
but hey what the hell
let's review what we know this is as
unlikely a theory as any since there is
absolutely no proof or evidence to
substantiate that Lily was even pregnant
at the time of her death furthermore as
just mentioned there's no indication
that Lily had reconciled with Snape at
this point in her life never mind
recovered a relationship to the point in
which she would consider him a close and
important enough figure to have him be
the Godfather to one of her children not
to mention the historical tension
between Severus and James so even if
Lily had forgiven Snape to the point
that she was willing to invite him into
her children's lives in such an
important and intimate way it's terribly
unlikely that James would have been okay
with this decision maripi gone to his
Credence Bare Bones biological mother
which brings us to the final bad theory
of 2022 that maripi gaunt Voldemort's
biological mother was also the mother of
credence bare bone as you may remember I
discussed this Theory right after the
release of Fantastic Beasts the secrets
of Dumbledore as I mentioned then this
Theory while incredibly entertaining is
simply not possible since marapi was
born six years after Credence of course
this would have made it pretty difficult
for her to be his mother not to mention
that the gaunt family also resided in
little hangleton not godric's Hollow
where aberforth Dumbledore credence's
biological father was living preceding
credence's birth and with that we've
come to the end of another video what
did you think did I miss any theories
from the past year that you thought were
the absolute worst please share your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed the video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
foreign